it's time for roses that rose say oh I
didn't smell any welcome everyone to
another week of The Bachelorette another
week of Jordan this time with a reveal
we finally heard from Jordan about his
estrangement from his brother Aaron but
we'll get to that first we have to talk
about Morris's cheers to horses so I
thought that the Bachelorette had
thought of every day possible but Nitto
some brilliant producer said what if
they went horse snuggling ah
Jojo took Alex on a one-on-one they
snuggled with the horse
he wore a weird outfit she called a week
out show I'm not joking then she said by
E so alex is gone finally the only
reason was that there was to instigate
Chad don't like milk don't need any shun
no it's delicious
cheers to Alex you had a good run at
doing what you were doing but happens
next what happens next
Oh another date when I can get behind
why Jordan got another one-on-one with
Jojo and they went grape stomping and
they stomp their feet on these barrels
and then they drank it and then I had to
google because I was confused
Cera's cheers to whatever was on our
feet once you stomp the grapes is it
already why they were drinking it like
it was already wine I think it's wine
this is wine very more I don't want to
put ice in it yet a lot of that liberal
desperation
okay so Jordan wow I was really on board
and then he said something that made me
more uncomfortable than anything that
has been said all season so Jordans
talking about hometown dates and he
tells Jojo
I really want you to come home and meet
mama I really want you to come we need
mama mama mama we're moving fast to
Jordan we're forgetting it it was weird
you got a southern accent for a second
nobody knew I blame it on the not wine
wine I guess but then things got weirder
because we heard more about Jordans
family
why doesn't Jordan talk to his brother
Aaron he didn't really explain why but
he did blame it on Aaron
me and Aaron don't really have that much
of a relationship
it's just kind of the way he's chosen to
to do life and I chose to stay close
with my family and my parents and my
brother and Jordan basically said
everything's Aaron - Aaron cheers to you
because this is gonna be a little storm
you gotta deal with from a very deep
talk about family - a Sister Wives
situation sister husbands Jojo had a
sleepover date with three dudes
jojo's group date was a sleepover in the
hotel it was at Amos sleepover of all
time does everyone remember when Kaitlyn
Bristowe took Nick v all out of date and
she had sex with him while the mics were
on take that divided by a hundred
subtract twelve and then shrink it into
just a millimeter of a thing and that's
how saucy this sleepover office they
play charades they made jokes about shad
you're still in this buddy can we get a
little never have I ever something so
that happened and James Taylor kind of
spent the whole episode realizing he was
in the friend zone and the JoJo's way
more into Robbie and in the end James
Taylor was sent home at the rose
ceremony by write a song about it
it's just starting to feel like it's
Jordan versus himself isn't it I feel
like in the end she's gonna pick Jordan
because something's gonna go wrong so
what did you guys think of this episode
what did you think of George big reveal
who's hire you on Jordans or errands
errands or Jordans jojo's of horses let
me know on twitter i am at lauren zima
let's shut this down and pretend it's
grape juice because that's more peachy
fine